US Open draft Amanda ballet onus he
works for CBS sports their golf reporter
she'll be there working the US Open
she'll join us here in a moment from
Pebble Beach now who has the first pick
in the draft did we give a man to see
Amanda knows what's going on so she's an
expert yes he covers this morning she
covers the sport she's there she's got
inside information about she gets third
pick the third pick all right I have the
last pick um
fritzy has next to less so it's Seton
McLovin
Amanda Paulie fritzy and then me is that
good enough for you guys ready yeah okay
Amanda how are you I'm good how are you
where are you right now
I am at Pebble Beach actually sitting
here watching looking at the ocean it's
beautiful out what kind of conditions
this week oh my gosh well I think I
think they're gonna get really lucky it
has been in the high 80s the early part
of this week and then starting tomorrow
it's supposed to drop down to 60s but
still sunny no rain in the forecast and
minimal wind so we could be seeing I
mean an unbelievable show this week if
these conditions remain as benign as
they're expected today Brooks koepka
wanted to know why he wasn't featured
and the Fox promo for the US Open in
their coverage feels like he's got a
good good point here that you know do we
just why it isn't Brooks koepka
is he just not exciting enough or we
don't know enough or he doesn't do
enough interviews
of course he's I listen he of course
he's exciting enough what he's doing the
run that he's on right now is historic
from what I was told he actually was in
a lot of the Fox promos it just happened
to be one that you saw he was not but in
like the majority of them he is I tend
to think that Brooks likes picking
something to put a chip on his shoulder
for the week to keep himself kind of
hungry and focused and so I don't know
how real his his anger is for that I
don't know I I feel like he might just
be telling himself
dori could give himself that fire that
he needs to go on to try to win I mean
another major championship it's just
it's insane what he's doing but it comes
from this focus right that like we
haven't seemed really in the modern era
with it with this type of consistency so
I think that's I think that's what it is
yeah I think that he's built a career
with a chip on his shoulder I think that
that's how he got to where he is but
there's not a lot of fanfare for him
it's almost as if you said hey you want
to watch Ricky Fowler or watch Brooks
koepka cap cos you know got a chance to
win whereas people are entertained by
Rickie Fowler and you know how he
dresses here so it's it's kind of an odd
thing where you're watching Kefka and
he's just like he's he's ruthless I mean
he just he doesn't care who you are he's
taking you down and leaving you in his
wake so but he's he's not the betting
favored Dustin Johnson is this week I'm
before we get to our picks the front row
seat and Paulie just had a bet I don't
know what the stakes are but there'll be
pretty high stakes Paulie says Brooks
koepka is he's taking him to to win and
finish in the top ten Seaton O'Connor
says he doesn't think Brooks koepka
finishes in the top ten which side would
you take right now Brooks koepka top ten
or outside looking in yeah I mean how
can you possibly say first Cassio's not
going to finish in the top ten when he's
won four of his last two US Open right
so yeah of course he's gonna so some
thoughts that he might win this week
okay I'm just this that's eaten do you
want to respond to Amanda I think that a
response will happen I'm not doubting
him I'm not it's just a member of my my
crack team here all right
who has the first pick in the draft seed
no Connor
you're not taking Brooks koepka because
you don't think you'll finished in the
top ten that is accurate okay
who are you taking all right so I have a
favorite that I want to take but I'm
gonna wait because I think they'll still
be there later but I'm gonna take Dustin
Johnson all right Dustin Johnson is off
the board okay so I'm up a mile at a
mile on think Brooks Kepler does it have
to go to Paulie I no no no that's
I'll take Caprica I'll take cap go here
okay some McLovin Amanda you're next you
know I'm gonna go with the emotional pic
and so if Phil Mickelson Phil went five
thirty to one
uh fritzy I believe you're next or no
paulie's next Eldrick woods Eldrick
Tiger Woods at ten to one I'm gonna grab
Rory McIlroy Rory McIlroy jr. the third
I got jordan Spieth back-to-back Jack
[Music]
might take my boys and irshaf Lee
because I just I think he's he's gonna
do it one of these days I think so all
right next
Fritzie I'm gonna go Ricky Fowler Manny
next up Paulie
Justin Rose please snoring Justin Rose
come on down next is I think it's Amanda
you love Marc Leishman okay Marc
Leishman is off the board
McLovin hi Justin Thomas Justin Thomas
is off the board seat no Connor back to
back Jack I really liked Xander chef Lee
by the way yeah that was my guy okay my
go Patrick Kent Lee and I can't play no
I'm gonna take him Chris Berman would
say okay Kent LAN who
Oh Tommy flea yes I thought you would
say farewell Jesus we're doing got it
all right McLovin I'll take Tony female
Tony FINA all right Amanda I knew you
were gonna do that and Paul II wanted
Francesco Molinari
already made a Jersey uh all right
Paulie let's bring this guy back out of
the mothballs Jason Day a day with
Tigers old caddy on the bag Fritzl is it
Fritzl Jeff I'm gonna grab John ROM John
ROM I'll go with the man who looks
better than his swing but his swing is
one of the best-looking ones on tour
I'll take Adam Scott and then I'm gonna
follow that one up god I'd love to go
Brent Snedeker after the way he played
over the week it's Ned's as we like to
call him a snitch you don't have a lot
of great nicknames on tour Amanda by the
way you know like lefty Phil Mickelson
come on well we're in a PC world so I
can't imagine that Joe blocker this
weekend would say and let's go out to 18
fairway Jesus here with his second show
just I can't imagine Jim Nantz saying
that on a CBS broadcast so oh I'm gonna
go Kate hate myself here I want to do
Webb Simpson again I begrudgingly take a
dekhi Matsuyama it's so boring
so that is that it you got two great
picks I do yeah okay is that is there
another round here one more okay go
ahead guys I'm
go with Bryson to Shambo for my Latin
alright alright alright who's next
Paulie not a great tipper but a great
player Matt Kuchar couch oh wow
Amanda I think you're next yeah you know
I'm gonna go with the big guy Kyra dust
after barn wrap mr. Anderson yes I'm
gonna go a old favorite of mine mr. Jim
Furyk who I believe is in the field so
on you have picked Furyk when he has
been your very loyal to Jim Furyk he
came up to us at Pebble Beach a super
nice guy yes he said thank you for
picking me and majors that I didn't
compete in cheap no counter with the
last pick I might go with one of my
other sleepers here then C will Kim C
152 one st. Donnie Kim jr. the third how
would you assess Tigers game he remanded
going into this yeah listen I I will
tell you when I saw him at the memorials
and you know he was extremely happy with
where his game was coming in to form on
Sunday and I said to him off camera I
said are you ready for pebble and he
gave me the biggest smile and said
absolutely and it kinda reminded me of
the same sort of calm excitement that he
showed during the Masters all week and I
really kind of felt like then he's ready
to do this again so I think he learned a
lot about what he needed to do to get
ready after you know the PGA
Championship performance he wasn't happy
about that but it's a learning curve for
him of how do you not play a whole lot
but still be ready to peak you know for
for the major so I think he has figured
this out he seems super confident at the
memorial obviously this is a place that
he knows how to win on like most places
on the PGA Tour so I think there's no
way you can count Tiger out this week
Thank You Amanda have fun this week
thank you guys Amanda Bally illness from
CBS Sports covering golf there for more
Dan Patrick show
in the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
streamed for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]